well I've been thinking for a while
we need to do one about Capitalism
because we get asked it a lotright
"Capitalism is the problem!"
it's a bit frustrating for me because it's like
it's so non-specific it's like okay well... yes...
problem with capitalism is different people have
very very different ideas of what the word means
all right um so it can become difficult to do
any sort of analysis of it because different
people have different ideas um so I'm going
to say provide the basic working definition
which some people disagree with but it's what I'm
going to use for this purpose of this discussion
which is capitalism is a system which has
a relatively small government relatively
low taxation people are expected to take
care of themselves with their own money
um yeah and then there's freedom to trade
freedom to own things basically it's a
people call it 'laissez-faire' system there's
not a lot of government control people do
whatever they want everybody's free to do
what they want it's important to realise once
you use that definition none of us live in fully
capitalist countries right the UK has NHS that's
not capitalist institution the UK has public fund
education that's not capitalist you know so we're
not about living a perfect capitalist system but
let's talk about capitalism which is the idea of
freedom to own freedom to trade and also
means freedom to generate inequality right
now there's something which is good about
capitalism which is that capitalism rewards
people for doing things that other people want so
if you can if you're making a lot of paintings and
nobody wants them you're going to make no money
but if you're making a lot of paintings that
people want then you are going to make money right
why'd the footballers make money in the capitalist
system because tons of people are willing to pay
to watch them so in a sense capitalism is good
because it incentivises all these peopleto play
football and people want to watchfootball
these kind of things right so there'slike a
philosophical idea behind it which is that
because everybody is free then you will get
rewarded if you do things other people want which
means in theory people should start doing things
that other people want which is good because we're
all helping each other out this is the this is
this is the idea behind it right the problem is
if you actually look at the outcomes of capitalism
lots of people have things which they really
really want or even need that they don't get so we
have a capitalist system and a lot of people can't
afford to feed their kids all right so you know
they want to feed their kids and there's enough
food for them to feed their kids, well you know, why
are they not feeding their kids? we have people who
work at jobs for homeless you know of course
they want homes but they're not getting homes
and what this reveals is there's one key flaw of
capitalism which is that capitalism doesn't reward
you for doing what people want, capitalism rewards
you for doing what people with money want right
you know there are people in poor countries
in the world that are blind and they just need
relatively inexpensive surgery to fix their
blindness but they don't get that because
they've got no ****ing money right, capitalism
doesn't give back to those people you know
you know you know you're a dentist right you
will see there are dentists that spend all
of their days doing expensive cosmetic
surgeries for wealthy people and at the
same time there's people who are in agony
of toothache who can't get a dentist right
and this is because capitalism doesn't reward you
for doing what people want capitalism rewards you
for doing what people with money want, if you
can do something that rich people want you can
make a ton of money right but if you can do you
know if you want to provide dental work for like
poor people in Africa or in Southeast Asia you're
not going to make no money for that because they
don't have any money right so once you understand
this then what you see is inequality is absolute
cancer at the philosophical root of capitalism
because if you have a broader equal society then
it works right because everybody has money so
youshould do the thing which lots of people want
but once you have inequality then it doesn't
matter if 99% of people hate something
you know if you do a job which sucks wealth
out of the poorest 99% and gives it to the 1%
you can get paid a ****ing ton of money for that,I
know because I did it right! capitalism works for the
people with money there's this phrase rightwhich
is "Freedom for the Heron is Death to theFishes"
right if you allow everybody freedom andwhat
the most powerful wants is to, what the most
powerful people want is to take everything from
everyone else then that's that's freedom right
that is freedom the problem is capitalism
is great when you have a broad distribution
and even then it's not necessarily great
right if you look at for example the US
the US is a very capitalistic economy for a long
period of time right and it has a lot of resources
so it did provide a great standard of living
fora lot of people, not if you're black right
if there's groups of people that don't have any
wealth, then they will not get well served under
capitalism and then if you make it really unequal
then that can be 90-95% of people that don't get
served under capitalism you see what I'm saying
so capitalism works philosophically & theoretically
when everybody has money, when everybody has
wealth, but we're moving towards the situation
that is why capitalism works relatively well
in Western Europe and did for the last 70 years
because lots of people have wealth so everybody...
capitalism is democracy but one pound = one vote
you see what I'm saying so if everybody has an
equal amount of money then everybody will get a
decent amount of what they want, but once you
movetowards extreme inequality then capitalism
will only serve the rich of course it will why would
capitalism give you anything if you have nothing
to offer for it? it's about freedom of trade
and if these people have all the power then
they will get all the stuff and what you start
to see is capitalism is so dynamic it creates
the physical infrastructure to perfectly mirror
the distribution of wealth because capitalism
serves the people with wealth so if you have
a broad wealth holding society then capitalism
will produce lots of middle-class houses and
middle class cars and middle class appliances
and middle class services and middle class theatres
and middle class cinemas right but if you have ex..
an economy where all of the world is with the very
rich then capitalism will give you extreme luxury
and poverty it will give you a extremely wealthytown
centre surrounded by impoverished slums which
is what the case in Mumbai, which is the case in
Johannesburg, the case in Sao Paulo, is the case
in every unequal country in the world and is
becoming the case here in London as well right
so the way I see capitalism (sorry I've
hit my mic) the way I see my capitalism
the way I see capitalism is it produces
good outcomes when everybody has wealth
when you are in a very unequal Society
It generally produces terrible outcomes
so you need to protect the wealth distribution
you need to protect the wealth distribution and
the problem you have is that capitalism tends
to destroy the wealth distribution so I'm not
saying I'm anti-capitalist that to me I think you
bring me a car and the car's not working I'm not
going to tell you I'm anti-cars you know I I have
studied this system it is broken in a specific way
that I think is fixable I know there will bepeople
out there saying 'ah no capitalism isbroken'
you need to destroy everything to bring itin
okay that's fine show me the blueprint for the
new society I'll have a look at the moment I do
want to prevent this disaster from happening and
it's the problem that they have right now is what
is most frustrating is the problem is so fixable
the problem is so fixable, it is a problem with the
wealth distribution we fix the world distribution
we fix the problem we can see a massive increase
in living standards a massive increase in living
standards you don't fix the wealth distribution
you won't fix the living standard so for me
you need to protect the distribution
the system and we're not doing it
um and you know like if people want to have a
discussion about what is the ideal system you
know is capitalism the best system could we have
other systems we can have that discussion but at
the moment the system that we have is falling
off of a cliff and I would prefer to prevent
that disaster from happening first because ifwe
don't do anything about what's happening now
it's going to be real real bad, it's going to bereal
real bad and um I there's this phrase youknow
'don't let the perfect be the enemy of thegood'
you know we're in a situation but I would say
don't let the perfect be the enemy of preventingthe
collapse of society at this point cos that's what
we're looking at, that's what we're looking at,
solisten let's let's fix the problem that we have
and then we can talk about is there a better way
to do this is there a better way to do this but
listen I'm not, I'm not a philosopher you knowum
I just don't want things to be really really****
and they're gonna be and we canstop them
If we fix the distribution
housing could be so much more affordable, wages
could be so much higher and we could have so
many more options in how we live our lives
someof them put a lot of money into paying
economists and think thanks to tell you that inequality
is important for the economy that is not true